Denali National Park and Preserve is
home to Mount McKinley the highest peak
in North America the mountain the
Athabascan Indians call Denali the
highway visitors to the park expect the
wildlife to just come up to the side of
the road but really everyone has to take
buses beyond a certain point and the
trick is that Ryan spot the wildlife up
in the mountains Grizzlies wolves moose
dall sheep terrible the Denali big 5
Alaska Safari stop look yonder and a
bear comes into view he is magnificent
huge thick coat just poking around for
breakfast so they'll spend quite pretty
much all of their day just digging for
roots eating getting enough fat for the
winter that's what most of the grizzly
bears will be doing this time of year is
just putting on weight for the winter
months and they can actually pass out
from eating so much as you head deeper
into the park has to lookout point
called polychrome pass the road is
perilous with a drop-off that could kill
but around one of those killer curves
the Alaska Range spreads out in front
Mount McKinley or Denali is hiding it's
so big that it makes its own weather
the mountain takes a little bit more
work
it's only out twenty percent of the time
so a lot of people that dream of seeing
it just need to come back again did you
guys see the mother a mother grizzly and
two cubs they are hungry and preparing
to hibernate the mother and her two cubs
are rooting around eating all the
vegetation Grizzlies have a reputation
for being major predators but in fact
around eighty percent of their diet is
vegetation grizzly sometimes come near
the road and for visitors the only
defense is their voice the bear
recognizes the different tones of human
voice and is frightened by them this
grizzly has a chocolatey brown coat at a
ravenous appetite an instinct to fatten
up and hibernate before the snows come
winters never far away in Alaska the
locals say when the fireweed blooms all
the way to the top winter's coming and
thus ends another magical season in
Denali